my key card doesn't work again  i'm sorry sir did did you have it near  your cell phone or your credit card at  any point  probably  yeah everyone's got cell phones and  credit cards everywhere and what do you  mean by near my cell phone or credit  card if it's here is that near that and  what's the radius and you know what my  cell phone and my  credit cards still work so what the [ __ ]  is wrong with your keycard  sir if you just calm down i'm i'm trying  to help you  what's your name and your room number  stand hope  217.  clack clock  sir  i'm sorry  there's no one by that name  in this hotel  look at the key card your [ __ ]  hampton in it's next door you all look  the same  [ __ ] you